bon forme somme mardi vie septembre
merci de nous rejoindre pour cette
nouvelle édition de votre journal
d'information tout de suite les titres
de votre actualité locale le
développement de l'enseignement privé
musulman la france compte une
quarantaine établissements
confessionnels de ce type dont celui de
montigny le bretonneux
cette année la classe de 6e vient d'être
placé sous contrat d'association avec
l'état à la verrière le groupe
mutualiste ngn fait peau neuve 100
millions d'euros investis pour une
reconstruction intégrale présentation du
futur établissement qui verra le jour en
la maison de l'entreprise de 50 ans dit
ne lance la nouvelle édition de son ski
entreprises challenge 30000 euros en jeu
pour soutenir vos projets explications
en plateau avec jean marc barr jeudi
chargé de relations entreprises et nous
parlerons également du nouveau pass
navigo à tarif unique en vigueur depuis
le 1er septembre
une aubaine pour les voyageurs mais
est-ce un bon coup politique à quelques
mois des élections le transport l'enjeu
des prochaines régionales en île de
france et ce soir je le disais nous
recevons jean-marc port gentil bonsoir
et merci d'être venus a sur un autre
plateau
vous allez nous parler du ch'ti
entreprise de challenge dans quelques
instants mais avant cela nous passons
donc à l'actualité de ce mardi c'est
l'actualité de ce mardi
c'est avant tout la colère des
buralistes aujourd'hui près d'une
centaine de buralistes s'étaient
mobilisés dans près de 80 villes de
france dans les yvelines ils ont même
déployé une banderole
hier sur la nationale 10 pour protester
contre le paquet neutre est la hausse du
prix du tabac qui pourrait s'élever
jusqu'à 10 euros pour en parler avec
nous nous sommes en ligne avec ceux
jean-françois vigouroux président de la
délégation des yvelines de la chambre
syndicale des buralistes jean-françois
vigour vous m'entendez ne soit alors est
ce que vous nous expliquer les
revendications des buralistes
revendications primaires c'est en fait
qu'on est contre le paquet neutre
marisol touraine qui est qui veut en
fait faire une différence entre le
paquet neutre le paquet générique le
paquet générique c'est ce qui a été voté
par le parlement
donc tous les pays européens rond
65 % de mentions salutaire mais marisol
touraine veut toujours faire plus parce
que c'est dans l'air du temps et leur
mieux en mieux faire que mieux faire que
les autres
donc il ya de faire 100% du paquet en
mention sanitaires c'est à dire que plus
aucune marque d'afficher plus aucun logo
et plus aucune couleur
tout sera donc marron et il y aura juste
sur la tranche sur la hauteur marquer
même qu'est ce que cela change vraiment
pour vous à buralistes pour nous si vous
voulez ça dénature totalement notre
notre outil de travail si vous voulez du
pour nous le paquet neutre c'est du
marketing sanitaire est ni plus ni moins
de chasse et et ça changera pas ça
changera pas le sa changera rien on voit
bien que en australie ils disent que ça
on a perdu 3 4 % de fumeurs
ça fait trois quatre ans on comprend que
la france la france doit faire face à
des doigts mettre en place des
prévention sanitaire pour éviter que les
citoyens français
on n'est pas contre en fait nous dans le
monde du tabac on n'est pas contre la
prévention il faut faire de la
prévention
et si on préfère prévention on veut que
tu as toi une harmonisation sur tous les
pays d'europe
on a déjà le paquet un paquet cher haut
niveau un des plus chers au niveau
d'europe donc ce qu'on veut c'est que si
on fait des mentions sanitaire qu'on le
fasse pour tout le monde pareil
et tout comme les prix c'est à dire que
on doit tous fait au même prix et
lorsque l'on sera tous au même prix
alors à son bras il n'y aura qu'un seul
à vouloir vivre la mobilisation
d'athènes consigne est ce que vous avez
d'autres actions prévues prochainement
il ya d'autres actions prévues qui sont
prévues sur toute la france
je peux pas vous dire exactement pour
que cela reste confidentiel
mais il ya d'autres actions de telus
très bien et bien merci
jean-françois vigouroux nous suivrons
donc cette actualité siens merci au
revoir hier le président de la
république annoncé la prise en charge
dans la france de 24 mille migrants ces
hommes et femmes qui fuient massivement
le conflit syrien bernard cazeneuve le
ministre de l'intérieur a envoyé une
lettre à tous les maires de france pour
les sensibiliser
à la situation de ces populations
civiles et remercié également les élus
qui ont accepté d'accueillir des
familles dans les yvelines certaines
villes comme la verrière jouy en josas
ou encore les mureaux on veut déjà fait
savoir leur souhait de prendre part à
cet effort d'humanité comme un jeu
propose ce site d'écouté le maire de la
verrière à mon âge on va s'adresser aux
citoyens vers hyérois pour leur dire
voilà vous pouvez vous aussi acteurs de
ces démarches de on a des partenaires
des bailleurs sociaux à des partenaires
locaux qu'on auquel on va s'adresser à
leur dire et si on sent dans un effort
on n'est pas obligé pas en accueillir
quinze vingts familles mais on peut être
accueillir quelques familles et puis à
l'échelle de l'agglomération
il y à des associations il ya des
services il ya dix villes qui peuvent
peut-être faire plus d'efforts que
d'autres voilà il est en tout cas plutôt
que de renvoyer à l'autre mais tronc
commun
mettons comme un autre en vie mettant en
commun nos moyens mettons en commun
notre humanité et selon nos confrères du
parisien les communes de saint cyr
l'école saint germain en laye et
montrent la ville ont déjà compte à elle
fait part de leur opposition à l'accueil
de ces réfugiés
à noter également parmi les nombreuses
déclarations à des politiques celle
d'henri guaino députés les républicains
des yvelines invité du club de la presse
hier soir sur europe 1 il a estimé que
l'effort d'accueillir 24 mille migrants
étaient considérables mais je cite que
nous pouvions le faire le député
s'oppose en revanche à l'idée des quotas
et souhaite que l'on s'occupe des causes
du problème
chaque année vous savez on parle encore
de la rentrée les établissements privés
musulmans sont l'objet d'une forte
demande d'inscription des demandes qui
ne veut qu'ils ne peuvent pas toujours
satisfaire car ils sont peu nombreux en
france depuis la rentrée 2015
l'institut de formation de saint quentin
en yvelines bénéficie de son premier
contrat d'association avec l'état pour
une classe des sixièmes les précisions
de williams elle tous les jours
un tiers de ces jeunes effectue un
trajet de plus de 40 kilomètres pour se
rendre à l'école
ils sont inscrits dans l'un des quatre
établissements musulmans privé du
département des yvelines
une offre qui ne répond pas à la demande
en moins
ici une demande d'inscription sur deux
aboutit en raison du nombre de places
disponibles
nous sommes restreints par les
cotisations scolaires qui sont qui
demeurent élevés en particulier quand
nous sommes hors contrat pour nos
classes haut record contre à la
cotisation scolaire est relativement
élevé et nous sommes aussi contraint par
l'espace parce que nous avons un
bâtiment qui bien qu'ils soient grands
on ne peut pas accueillir toutes les
demandes et aujourd'hui nous nous
limitons à une classe par niveau par
exemple le 24 août dernier l'institut de
formation de saint quentin en yvelines a
signé son premier contrat d'association
avec l'état pour cette classe de sixième
le directeur de l'établissement lui
espère étendre ce statut aux autres
classes au sens propre du terme c'est
être associé au service public de
l'éducation nationale dans les
établissements privés qui sont sous
contrat d'association veut vraiment dire
qu'ils sont associés à la mission à la
mission d'enseignement aux côtés des
établissements publics
pour être éligible un établissement doit
avoir fonctionné pendant cinq années
hors contrat pour son septième
anniversaire l'institut de formation de
saint quentin en yvelines a pu
bénéficier de ce dispositif qui en plus
des subventions permettra une baisse des
cotisations pour les familles de cette
classe on estime qu'à minima la
cotisation scolaire de 3500 euros à
minima devrait être divisé par deux nous
y voyons un signe supplémentaire de de
reconnaissance de l'état de nos de notre
démarche est sa volonté justement de
nous d'appuyer d'appuyer notre travail
l'institut de formation de saint quentin
en yvelines qu'on près de 200 élèves
pour des classes allant du cp à la
seconde
en france il n'existe qu'une
cinquantaine d'établissements de ce type
avec encore très peu de contrats en
association avec l'état et l'institut
fait mais je vienne de la halle verrière
va bientôt faire peau neuve ce matin les
équipes ont présenté le projet de
reconstruction du site doit commencer
dans le courant de l'année 2016
l'établissement le plus important du
groupe prend en charge des patients de
la pré adolescence à la personne âgée
mélanie poquet étaient sur place
c'est à ça que ressemble ras le nouvel
institut sur le site marcel rivière
il regroupera les patients des centres
de niveau
thiey centre gériatrique créée en 1974
et marcel rivière établissements de
santé mentale construit en 1959
la plupart des pavillons d'habitation
n'ont pas évolué depuis cette année
l'année 1959
donc oui il y avait un besoin en santé
mentale en ce qui concerne le bâtiment
l'autre hôpital denis forestier la
médecine courts séjours et les soins de
suite les besoins auraient pu attendre
encore quelques temps mais les raisons
d'efficience économique ont fait
l'ensemble en une seule fois les
bâtiments actuels d'une capacité de 409
lits seront détruits pour faire place au
futur établissement
à l'ouverture le futur institut contre à
4 185 lits et 45 place pendant les
travaux le site re le site gériatrique
de denis forestier n'est pas touché par
les travaux il fonctionne de la même
manière par contre l'institut marcel
rivière voit une diminution partielle de
ce nombre de lits de psychiatrie
durant cette période des travaux puisque
nous construisons comme l'on dit en site
occupé le centre se structurera en
quatre pôles cliniques pour prendre en
charge les patients de la préadolescence
aux personnes âgées
des travaux qui vont aussi concerner la
population vers hyéroise et alentours on
a beaucoup discuté que les jeunes sur
l'originalité finalement de la conduite
du chantier on veut un chantier
environnemental de grande qualité
et puis que la même gêne entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire
s'implique avec l'entreprise dans
différentes clauses faire travailler des
sous-traitants locaux former des jeunes
privilégier l'emploi local et la
formation
représentant un investissement de plus
de 100 millions d'euros
le nouvel institut devrait voir le jour
en 2010 9 les démolition des bâtiments
actuels commenceront en mars 2016 et est
temps maintenant de passer à notre
entretien de cette édition je le
rappelle nous recevons jean marc barr
jeudi de la maison de l'entreprise
vous êtes venu nous parler du style
entreprises challenge car la fin des
inscriptions approche c'est le 18
septembre il me semble oui tout à fait
bonsoir tout à fait donc
18 septembre clôture des inscriptions
pour ce concours qui a pour vocation de
valoriser l'entrepreneuriat
entrepreneuriat et promouvoir évidemment
les initiatives de créateurs et de chefs
d'entreprises sur saint quentin en
yvelines
alors il ya plusieurs de leurs
catégories dans ce concours s'adresse
nouveauté de ce concours quatre
catégories nos créateurs d'entreprises
bien évidemment créateurs aussi
d'emplois et d'initiative
les chefs d'entreprises du territoire
commerçants artisans prestataires de
services une catégorie innovation qui
permet de récompenser les projets les
plus innovants du territoire est une
catégorie entrepreneur étudiant qui est
dans le cas de dispositif notamment lié
à l'université de saint quentin en
yvelines donc trente mille en trombe et
l'euro sont à temps je commence à se
répartir se distribuer entre alors sur
les quatre catégories les dotations sont
repartis en fonction des
des notes que vont attribuer le jury
donc on va avoir une première phase de
présélection de dossiers qui vont
attribuer globalement 5 6 candidats par
catégorie pour les amener dans une
grande finale notamment par le biais
d'un pitch de 5 à 10 minutes où les
différents entrepreneurs nous
présenterons leurs dossiers et le
meilleur vaincra donc c'est un peu voilà
un grand un grand oral pour les
entrepreneurs le jury a je le rappelle
est composé de partenaires comme edf
mais il ya aussi plusieurs banques
tous deux vont examiner les dossiers
voir justement les candidats les
critères de sélection ça va être un
projet original c'est un projet
pertinent un projet j'espère qu'elle
vous axé sur l'environnement
alors ça va être un mix un peu de tout
ça on va dire ce sont des projets
évidemment entre guillemets qui tienne
la route qu'ils sont viables évidemment
économiquement et aussi qu'ils ont un
intérêt un impact sur sur le territoire
de saint quentin
que ça soit sur le volet création
entrepreneuriat ou innovation bien
évidemment est ce que par rapport à une
certaine une servitude et gorée île et
vous avez déjà commencé à recevoir des
dossiers les jeunes entrepreneurs c'est
une catégorie beaucoup de dossiers
bah disons on a beaucoup d'entreprises
du territoire aujourd'hui qui sont
intéressés par ce concours du fait aussi
de la spécificité qu'on ouvre à toutes
les entreprises du territoire n'y a pas
forcément de critères d'âge ou de taille
au niveau des entreprises
donc nous recevons évidemment des
candidatures sur cette catégorie là nous
avons aussi des dossiers qui viennent
liés à l'innovation est aussi évidemment
les créateurs d'entreprise grâce à son
court ya plusieurs entrepreneurs qui ont
réussi à se lancer est ce que vous avez
un exemple qui pourrait inspirer ceux
qui hésitent peut-être à s'inscrire
oui tout à fait j'ai un exemple qui peut
être remarquable je pense à au créateur
de la société centimes et aux benjamins
du pays qui était venu nous rencontrer
pour un projet de création de
distribution de chewing gum un projet
qui au jour
depuis donc a été lauréat de notre
concours sur l'édition 2013 et qui
aujourd'hui draine quelques millions
d'euros dé de la création d'emplois au
niveau local et qui est aussi une
représentativité au niveau national donc
c'est un bel exemple de réussite sur un
projet de distribution du film eh bien
merci
sur notre plateau alors je le rappelle
la fin des inscriptions c'est le 18
septembre plus de précisions sur le site
www.skype.com n'hésitez pas à aller y
faire un tour et le passé navigo à tarif
unique c'est dorénavant est dorénavant
pardon une réalité pour plus de 3
millions huit cent mille francs si bien
70 euros par mois pour se rendre du
coeur de paris à la zone la plus reculée
de notre région pour en parler avec nous
en plateau wilfried est riche on sera
repris un bon soir florane effectivement
l'information mérite que l'on s'y
attarde un peu
car cette révolution sur le plan
tarifaire en place officiellement depuis
le 1er septembre c'est un élément qui va
jouer dans l'issue du scrutin des
prochaines régionales à 6 et 13 décembre
les électeurs se rendent aux urnes et il
ya fort à parier qu'au moment de faire
leur choix dans l'isoloir ceux qui
utilisent le train ils sont tout de même
un peu plus de 3 millions presque 4
millions vous l'avez rappelé il ya fort
à parier et qu ils se demanderont ce que
le ou la nouvelle présidente de l'île de
france fera de ce fameux pass navigo
alors petit rappel tout d'abord le pass
navigo version 2015-2016 comment ça
marche c'est simple avant le 1er
septembre pour se rendre de la zone une
à la zone 5 la plus éloignée il fallait
débourser plus de 116 euros
dorénavant ce sera 70 plus en fait d'un
trajet plus l'économie mensuel est
importante
à noter que les abonnements pour les
plus petits trajets qui coûtait moins
cher que 70 euros par mois sont
maintenus qu'en pensent les usagers
voici quelques avis parce que c'est une
bonne idée ça permet aux gens qui sont
banlieue d'accéder de circuler un peu
partout à 70 euros
c'est ça
mais je crois que c'est une bonne chose
et j'avoue que c'est assez intéressant
ce prix là pour vous les 5 0 vu que pour
deux zones je payais à peu près 20 euros
donc quoi ça peut être intéressant
le nouveau pass navigo je pense que
c'est une bonne chose parce qu'ils
savent avoir table à tout le monde pour
moi je pense en vain mot du coup je
payais 120 euros et là quand je paie
presque la moitié serait oui bon c'est
bien ça permet qui est pas de
déséquilibre entre les gens qui habitent
dans diffère des différents les
différentes régions et dans les
différentes zones et que ça met tout le
monde au même niveau alors le pass
navigo à tarif unique ça séduit
forcément linverse ce serait surprenant
le président du conseil régional jean
paul huchon ne manque pas de rappeler
qu'il est celui qui a permis cette
première mondiale en toute modestie bien
sûr lors cette conférence de presse
était en fin de semaine dernière il
rappelle son engagement régulièrement
quitte d'ailleurs à tacler dans son
propre camp de bonne guerre tout même
quand on se souvient de la façon dont il
a été évincé lorsqu'il souhaitait
briguer un nouveau mandat
je fais bien que les verts 10 c'est
super c'est nous les communistes et
c'est super c'est nous et que les
socialistes est très malin c'est fort
etc
mais il faut le faire et qu'est ce qu'il
a fait qu'est ce qu'il a fait il suffit
pas de déclamer il faut faire côté
politique justement les frais de quelles
sont les réactions
alors si les critiques n'ont pas manqué
au moment de mettre en place ce pass
navigo personne n'imagine véritablement
revenir dessus aujourd'hui vous voyez ce
tweet ce tout d'abord de cécile duflot
les écologistes étaient favorables à se
passe depuis le début mais elle veut
souligner son implication parce que
rappelons le les verts et le ps n'ont
pas conclu d'accord pour les régionales
l'idée d'une liste commune dès le
premier tour ce n'est pas vraiment
d'actualité le candidat du front
national valeron de saint-just et s'est
lui fendu d'un communiqué pour expliquer
qu'en cas de victoire il n'y aurait pas
de changement sauf sur le mode de
financement du dispositif il ira
chercher les fraudeurs pour faire
rentrer de l'argent dans les caisses
quant à valérie pécresse la candidate
l'est républicain elle se serait bien
passé de ce dispositif elle parle de
mesures électoralistes
elle tacle d'ailleurs aussi sur le
montant de la facture un tarif unique
cela signifie 480
5 millions d'euros de recettes en moins
qui va payer d'ailleurs oui qui va payer
la réponse de jean pollution enfin vous
savez quand vous êtes sur un sujet comme
celui là aussi large aussi
révolutionnaire qui concerne que 4
millions de personnes allaient chercher
à savoir si ça sera je dirais 350 400
quelle importance assez c'est quelque
chose que nous maîtrisons pas nous notre
budget il est équilibré
le mode de financement menée tout de
même pas très claires surtout la
conséquence probable de ce tarif unique
c'est la hausse de la fréquentation dans
les transports alors que les nouvelles
infrastructures ne sont pas encore en
service pour le grand paris on sait
qu'il faudra tout de même attendre et
quelques années les usagers pourrait
finalement ne pas apprécier ce cadeau
malgré tout au ps on veut assumer cet
héritage de jean paul huchon pour cette
campagne écouté benoît hamon député des
yvelines candidat aux régionales aux
côtés donc du nouveau candidat
socialiste et c'est claude bartolone
benoît hamon qui est en charge du projet
de son parti déclarations faites sur le
plateau de ce journal vendredi dernier
on a eu un engagement extrêmement fort
combattue par madame pécresse et que
nous avons mis en oeuvre j'espère
qu'elle le gardera en dépit du fait
qu'elle les combats dessus si jamais
elle devait être à jour présidente de la
région en tout cas qu'elles s'engagent
là dessus mais on pourrait devoir pour
éviter les mauvaises surprises
il faut à mon avis ce que je vois je me
battrai pour ça non seulement poursuivre
en matière de politique de transport ce
que vous avez commencé mais ce donner
une nouvelle énergie avec l'autre bord
eh bien merci wilfried on veut retrouver
la semaine prochaine pour le retour du
café poétique avec la mère des
clayes-sous-bois véronique côté millard
et dès vendredi pour l'édition du week
end du journal
merci forum est un mot de ce sport il
n'y a pas eu de miracle pour les cougars
de montigny le bretonneux heures
demi-finales de play-off de 2e division
les outsiders ini montant se sont
inclinés contre clermont ferrand 14 à 4
dont le premier match et 9 à 3 dans le
second
retour sur ces matches avec michael et
mid et demi d'euros pardon et elodie
moines clermont ferrand est décidément
la bête noire des cougars de
montigny-le-bretonneux cette saison
après avoir perdu quatre fois en quatre
matchs contre les auvergnats saison
régulière désigne montant se sont une
nouvelle fois incliné à domicile en
demi-finale des play-off de 2e division
et saint quentinois n'ont rien pu faire
dans les deux premiers matchs de leur
série
score final 14 à 4 dans la première
manche et 9 à 3 dans le second acte on
avait pour stratégie en fait de décès de
restés proches au niveau du score parce
qu'ils avaient un bon lanceur américain
malheureusement on n'a pas pu le faire
on a commis quelques erreurs en défense
ils ont vite pris le large et après on
n'a pas pu remonter sur le score tous
les frappeurs frappe tous les frappes et
remettre la balle en jeu et ça c'est
vraiment un avantage contrairement à
nous qui avons pas réussi avec tous nos
frappeurs a frappé comme il faut pour
espérer se qualifier en finale de
playoffs les cougars n'auront pas le
droit à l'erreur lors de leur
déplacement en auvergne dimanche 13
septembre une seule défaite sur les
trois matches les empêcheraient
d'accéder à la finale
ce qu'il faut rectifier c'est peut-être
un peu plus de concentration au niveau
défensif et reprend un peu les
automatismes de la saison en attaque on
a eu une coupure d'un mois
on a repris l'entraînement la semaine
dernière donc on n'est pas encore tout à
fait prêt on a montré de bonnes choses
maintenant il nous manque les
automatismes qu'on avait en saison et
alors qu'on les retrouve très vite parce
que
de trois prochains matchs la semaine
prochaine le sans faute et donc
obligatoire pour continuer de rêver à la
montée en première division la saison
prochaine et les rencontres sportives
vous les retrouverez dans l'agenda de ce
vendredi dans le journal du vendredi
justement en parlant de sport quelles
activités allez vous faire cette année
pour les indécis
il fallait se rendre ce week-end au
forum des associations
nous étions à celle de montigny le
bretonneux au stade pierre de coubertin
48 section sportive et 69 sections
culturelles étaient présentes
la ville a d'ailleurs reçu cette année
la mention de la ville la plus sportive
des yvelines par le comité olympique
départemental
nous avons rencontré une association de
théâtre la compagnie de la bobine
elle a été créée en 2005 et mais c'était
sa première participation au forum
on écoute c'est une association mini
thèse qui est qui s'intéressent au
théâtre contemporain c'est une troupe
donc constitué de passionnés théâtre des
débutants des très expérimenté et chaque
année en fait
à partir de la rentrée on monte un
nouveau projet qu'on présente fin fin
mai et en juin à la salle jacques brel à
montigny-le-bretonneux puis aussi au
théâtre du ranelagh à paris et on rejoue
un voisin et ike rhône à la rentrée et
après on redémarre un nouveau projet et
surtout restez avec nous dans un instant
sur téléphiles le retour du 7-8 société
avec nouradine alliés premier débat de
la saison autour de la réforme du
collège alors qu'est ce qui coince
qu'est ce qui bloque la mobilisation se
poursuit contre le projet de la ministre
najat vallaud belkacem
un appel a été lancé pour une grève le
17 septembre en plateau vous retrouverez
responsables politiques du ps du parti
chrétien démocrate ainsi que des
syndicalistes sldt et sns le 7-8 société
c'est bien sûr à revoir sur notre site
internet comme l'intégrité de nos
munitions et de nos reportages c'est la
fin de cette édition je vous remercie de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve
demain à 18 heures pour le direct et
pour une nouvelle édition du journal
je vous souhaite une excellente soirée